el mosquito del dengue tiene los días
contados hace 10 años investigadores
brasileños y británicos trabajan juntos
para crear una versión transgénica del
aedes aegipty el insecto urbano más
peligroso de brasil
en estas jaulas tenemos a bebés amigos
son mosquitos machos modificados que
recibieron dos genes adicionales uno de
ellos es el marcador y el segundo es el
gen auto limitador que causa la muerte
de las hembras del aedes en la fase de
larvas deciden ustedes ya las féminas
las máquinas de levantar
este laboratorio ya ha producido mil
millones de mosquitos transgénicos a
partir de huevos como estos
cuando precisamos eclosionar los huevos
de aedes amigos los colocamos en un
sistema de acuacultura aquí se
desarrolla primero en el estado de larva
y después de crisálida
natal entro en esta empresa en 2016 como
voluntaria brasil pasaba por una
epidemia de cica y esta bióloga estaba
preocupada con los casos de microcefalia
en bebés causada por esta enfermedad
cinco años después es directora de
oxitec en brasil
los huevos de los mosquitos transgénicos
son colocados en estas cajas después de
15 días los insectos ya adultos salen
para copular es cuando empieza un ciclo
de reproducción que culmina con la
muerte de todas las larvas hembras aquí
los resultados de este experimento son
alentadores en una ciudad cercana se
consiguió reducir un 96% la población de
mosquitos ahora esta tecnología puede
ayudar a controlar la malaria en otros
países
en todo lo que hacemos en brasil será
transferido aquí y nos ayudará a
desarrollar programas para áfrica y
américa latina para combatir la malaria
sin volver la empresa asegura que estos
mosquitos son especies invasoras y que
su desaparición no afecta al ciclo de
vida de otros animales